we were kind of like wondering what
people want to know about the game in
the long term I mean once you get past
this late game content these dungeons
these huge boss says he maybe find all
the legendary weapons we're kind of
wondering what people might want out of
it or like what we personally might want
out of it and dlc down the stretch in
2017 or after whenever they choose to
keep supporting the game until but Jake
I don't know you've been playing I think
you said about like 12 hours now around
the AI think I'm around 12 hours now I'm
even like from now from what you've
heard from Pete and like about the late
game content can you think of anything
that you'd think this game should add or
maybe you would just be like more of the
same late game cons that we have now
though I mean after hearing what Peter
was saying about the those late game
dungeons and after like hearing what it
said in the guide i think late game
dungeons would be cool really far down
the road however i think right now it
would be nice to have more customization
options I know the car you can change
colors you can add decals right but I
kind of don't like what any of my
characters are wearing leather boys yeah
and I think you can like change some of
them but I think I also heard you say
that you can't really buy new stuff in
the game so you're stuck with your
leather zippered up you can't buy
there's there's a whole equipment menu
for a tire and you can't buy any yeah
you start out with like four options for
each right but it's two outfits that
have the option to put on a jacket or no
yeah so it's just let's be honest it's
just too so are we assuming they are
setting it up for DLC and feature like
that or like maybe microtransactions I
hope so like what the hell you're stuck
with this dude showing off his six-pack
like is unzipped leather yeah or you put
him in like these like white chino pants
and like I don't get like oh yeah like
it's the options big blow they suck my
family owns like Hotel in the Florida
Keys yeah like I'm okay with Noctis I'm
okay with with prompt oh I guess but
yeah Gladio and ignis I just found
myself like whoa and Justin brought up a
good point just inhaled was like wait
you mean I can't wear classic Final
Fantasy gear like I don't get to find
these like rat outfits and I was like no
but that sounds awesome like I would
love to dress prompt oh a pike cloud
Gary mean like perfect fit you know
there's there so many of those instances
it knocked us could be squall if we
didn't wanted to go there don't be
outfits even like change attributes
slightly too they say
kinda weird to only have two or four you
so you do at one point unlock another
one but it sick one more one more right
and I found myself more caught up in the
fact that I hated the way my characters
looked then oh I like the way that this
benefits my stats you know yeah i would
i would pick something that made me
weaker because I didn't have to stare at
a dumb outfit I do that I yeah I would
too yeah that all the time like very
soup all out like so it's like these
stats look better but you look done with
like a piece of metal sticking out of
here Jess so we're gonna even given new
earrings though or the six key vest yeah
like he looks he looks like a rich
person trying to like fit in with
commoners in that outfit like yeah his
clothes don't fit he doesn't know how to
wear a hat like it's perfect for the
desert too yeah he looks like he'll be
sweating at all all right so new
equipment and just accessories clothing
in general would be good beyond that
weapons merchants sell one or two
weapons like I think for any character
the most weapons i have is like eight or
nine so you said like the lake game a
lot of the cool parts of the Lakers
coming across these the legendary
weapons that your forefathers had well
sort of so those aren't traditionally
weapons those are super powered and when
you use them they drain your HP so
there's sort of like something you use
when you're feeling very confident and
you don't need to worry but most of the
time when you're doing the high level
stuff you can't use them so it'll put
you at a disadvantage so you do use just
standard weapons but there is a quest
line right now that I've opened where
I'm seeking a different set of legendary
weapons and those are actual like real
ones so I'm hoping to get those but it's
just one per per weapon type I'm not
finding like a suite of swords that look
rad or offer a lot of different
properties there are some differences
but to go to a shop and just see one
sword the entire game is [ __ ] like
did you because you like don't even
really see the see the swords and stuff
unless you're fighting like it almost
seems like why don't you just have more
and like that like yeah yeah it pisses
me off its it's not enough that I I
think about it long term but reflecting
on it now it's like yeah that is really
dumb that is really super bad like it
doesn't hurt combat but it hurts my
ownership over my character yeah in open
world games especially RPGs of this
magnitude I kind of want to see my
character
look different at the end or at least
like play different with different
weapons or something you do look
different at the end uh-huh but is it
because of equipment or outfits no are
you here you are being spoiler territory
should stop talking not really okay but
if they become incident today becoming
saturday beginning of the game okay it's
is it's it's like very obvious
foreshadowing in like it there's no
question that it's foreshadowing it's
interesting but in the sense that i
would like to keep like building my
character with new gear and whatnot
drawn the game which I don't I don't
again I don't is that like a final
fantasy trope or no not like a lot like
uh not in terms of changing appearance
okay but in terms of having a lot of
options yes that is if you want to call
a trip i call it you know yeah tradition
okay um something else that might be
kind of cool like i actually haven't
found any of the summons yet and it
seems like they're a pain in the ass to
actually something it's not like there's
a lot are there but it might be cool to
have more maybe there's four there's for
you see you see more in the game but you
can only use for and if you're lucky you
will cast two of them it's really they
need yeah you didn't you sounded pretty
sour on the some it was one it was one
of the bad notes on the review one of
the things that definitely did stand out
to me more than the lack of swords which
I you know wasn't didn't feel egregious
enough for me to get that upset about in
the big picture but the summons oh my
god the game makes such a big deal about
them and you can never freaking cast
them you have to be at a certain like
this health state in battle and in a
certain region but that's [ __ ] even
if you're in those states in that place
you can't cast those freakin summons I
was I knew the rules I'd it was told to
me by the press the PR team I spent an
hour trying to summon Leviathan didn't
happen didn't you have to be nerd what
yeah I was going on your water as you're
correct when you're helpless really love
I went I went to the ocean coast i went
on a lake I went on a river and
Leviathan was somewhere else just
[ __ ] off I'm saying it all i want for
christmas the mariah carey version yeah
and so like you getting these huge
battles not when not when you're just
trying to summon them right but in the
game you get in these huge battles and
in past final fantasy games you'd be
like you know what I'm going to kick
your ass with afraid right now I'm gonna
cast us summon because that is most
powerful spell I have and you can't stop
me but now someone's will appear just
because the magical conditions are met
but it could be in a battle where you
don't need their help you know all right
I don't know is there anything else we
want to talk about it is released Dave's
I'm adding on a deal but then I mean I
imagine in a game like this if they do
when they when they do eventually
release DLC it'll be stuff that will
reward people have been playing for a
while I would assume maybe more dungeons
for the people that did like 100 perseus
like many hours or however long it might
take and I'd like to reward them rather
than people that are just getting in I'm
curious to like you had final fantasy
13-2 final fantasy 13 3 final fantasy 10
to like do you think they'll be like
like DLC could be Final Fantasy 15 2 I
had that thought the other day but so
the thing is the story doesn't leave a
lot of room for anything like that it
there is there is there's a little bit
of room for it but but not in the sense
yeah that I can be like oh yeah I can
see where this is going I could I could
not tell you where I think but I know we
might continue maybe with like different
characters or is that Tara to this at a
different final fantasy and because I
don't know a tradition but like cuz I
really do love the world like I'm having
that much fun just exploring the world
would be cooled the sea dlc I mean the
world's already huge but maybe after a
while like have a new area maybe not to
the same size but here you can go to
maybe new characters you plays or like a
new sort of side story kinda like you
guys hang out blood and wine earlier
actually you know what that brings to
mind so so Sid right he's a recurring
character a lot of final fantasy games
he's in this one and he is an old friend
of your father now there is a point in
the game where you see like it's not
really a spoiler you just see like a
photograph of Sid and your father and
two other guys like 30 years ago right
it's like a mirror image of what you're
currently doing in the game but the
generation before you I could see DLC
that uses those characters to tell the
story back then that that that's
actually probably where I would expect
they could go and still justify the DLC
without having to jump through hoops
like yeah how does this fit right well
it fits because it took place before
different characters maybe same
abilities or at least the same battle
system interesting all right well let's
final fantasy 15 and the DLC we kind of
want to see down the road but uh yeah
let us know what you guys think one
you play more of it what you think we
could see in DLC down the road where you
think the story could go from here what
more additions to the open-world you
want to see let us know in the comments
below
[Music]